[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes le quinquennat
qui s'achève est un échec
aucune des promesses faites par le
candidat sortant n'a été tenue sauf pour
les plus favorisés
le chômage est au plus haut voir d'achat
au plus bas la précarité par tous
l'égalité nulle part je vous propose le
changement le changement c'est d'abord
le redressement serré maîtrise de la
finance je la mettrai au service de
l'économie
c'est le soutien aux entreprises qui
produisent en france et notamment les
pme et je créerai une banque publique
d'investissement qui accompagnera leur
développement
je conditionnerait les aide à la
localisation en france de la production
je soutiendrai la transition écologique
énergétique et notamment les énergies
renouvelables nous en avons besoin
le redressement c'est aussi retrouver de
la croissance en europe
je rends négocierait donc le traité
européen signé par le candidat sortant
et qui aggravent l'austérité le
changement c'est aussi la justice c'est
taxer les revenus du capital comme ceux
du travail
c'est dissuader les rémunérations
indécentes en imposant à 75 % les
revenus supérieurs à un million d'euros
la justice c'est à lui et la hausse de
la tva décidée
il y a plusieurs semaines c'est protéger
le pouvoir d'achat
en bloquant les prix des carburants
pendant trois mois en encadrant les
loyers en allégeant les factures d'eau
et d'électricité la justice et garantir
l'accès de tous à la santé en limitant
les dépassements d'honoraires en
renforçant l'hôpital public la justice
et assurer l'égalité professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes la
justice et partir à la retraite à 60 ans
quand on a l'ensemble de ses annuités la
justice et aider les familles et
j'augmenterai l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire de 25% dès l'été la justice
c'est garantir la sécurité partout et
pour tous
et je crée 1000 postes supplémentaires
par an dans la police la gendarmerie et
la justice
enfin le changement c'est la réussite
pour la jeunesse l'école sera ma grande
priorité avec la création de 60000
postes sur cinq ans le rétablissement de
la formation initiale des enseignants
je lancerai pour l'emploi le contrat de
génération celui qui lie les seniors et
les jeunes et je créerai cent cinquante
mille emplois d'avenir
le changement c'est l'exemplarité au
sommet de l'état dans les comportements
dans les nominations dans les choix
la justice sera indépendante pour lutter
contre la corruption
les partenaires sociaux seront reconnus
les élus locaux respecter les
associations encourager et l'etat sera
impartial je suis socialiste je veux
rassembler la gauche et les français de
l'hexagone comme de l'outre-mer autour
de ce que nous avons de plus beau les
valeurs de la république la liberté
l'égalité la dignité la laïcité
je ne prends devant vous que des
engagements que je suis capable de tenir
j'ai confiance je connais nos atouts la
france est une grande nation
c'est ensemble que nous sortirons de la
crise
le 22 avril par votre vote vous pouvez
décider de changer changer d'avenir
changer de politique
changer de président le changement c'est
maintenant
[Musique]